Before we go too much further, I want to teach you a quick little Python thing
about how to do string substitution.
This will make generating our HTML a little bit more convenient.
If we have a string in Python that's represented like this.
This is a string that will probably be returning something like this in our web app--
you know--a little bit HTML with some contents.
If we want to return a lot of different types of bold contents with different text,
it's a pain because we have to make this whole string everytime.
Instead we can do something like this.
Okay, so here we have the same structure of the string.
We still have got our tags for bold,
but I've replaced the contents with this %s,
and what this does is if we follow the string with a % sign and then a variable,
it will substitute the contents of this variable for %s.
So if this were instead a, and a = "some bold text",
when we print this string, when we print "%s % a",
we'll actually get output that looks like this,
and this is how it can generate the strings.
So this is really convenient because we could have a function that just substitutes
1 variable into a string, and then we don't have to build that string over and over again.
Okay, so time for a quick quiz.